bon et puis est-ce que l'immigration est
l'une des grandes solutions à la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre dont on parle la
politique d'immigration au canada est en
tout cas dommageables pour l'ensemble du
pays et pour le québec notamment selon
l'économiste pierre fortin dans le cadre
d'une étude préparée pour le ministère
de l'immigration du québec pierre fortin
affirme que le québec devrait avoir le
contrôle total entier de son immigration
on le rejoint ce soir pierre fortin
professeur émérite au département des
sciences économiques de lui et j'ai eu
qu'à mme pierre fortin bonsoir bonsoir
vous poser un regard quand même sévère
dans l'étude sur la proche sur la
gestion de l'immigration du gouvernement
fédéral est ce qu'ottawa se trompent
selon vous sur toute la ligne
présentement en misant sur l'immigration
pour assurer la croissance la prospérité
du pays
oui on pense qu'avec eux 450 milles et
éventuellement 500 1000
immigrants louvre au paradis on va
réussir à faire un canada qui
premièrement vont être beaucoup plus
grande taille qui vont être plus riches
qui veulent plus + 1 dans le monde et
ben c'est le système de grande fierté
d'être canadiens pourraient être
améliorés avec latin et l'objectif naze
c'est sur le plan démographique on veut
être cinq millions de canadiens un
chalet 2100 alors qu'on vit présentement
38 millions et donc on présente ça comme
étant une solution quand même une
solution économique une solution à la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre est-ce que ça
en est une
oui la pop eu lieu il ya trois choses
qui sont recherchées premièrement que
beaucoup plus d'immigration aiderait à
résoudre des problèmes de plus 1000
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre deuxième marque
e sarit girel vieillissement de la
population parce que les migrants
moyenne sondage un peu plus jeune que la
moyenne de la population
et puis troisièmement que le niveau de
vie progresserait plus rapidement
croissance du pib par habitant seraient
plus heureux alors
quand on on passe en revue de la
littérature scientifique sur ces trois
points alors on se rend compte qu'aucun
de ces aucune de ces trois affirmations
la trouve
mai puis de la part des recherches
existants
premièrement le
pib par habitant le revenu par habitant
est relativement insensibles
l'immigration prenez juste par exemple
la croissance économique dans la région
de québec la région métropolitaine de
québec - c'est la plus élevée au canada
de plus 20 ans
or au québec qui a peu à québec qui est
presque aucun ni migrants qui arrivent
seulement 7 % de la population reste
immigrantes alors qu'à vancouver par
exemple aller vers ce ou en eau 15 5% de
la population qui est un génie migrent à
la croissance économique par epd à la
croissance nous vite et plus faible que
quelqu es belle donc ça veut pas dire
que les l'immigration est négative pour
la croissance économique mais ça veut
dire que le pousse pas dans la direction
d'une croissance économique
perhaps temps du niveau de vie qui soit
plus répond quand on a un million de
postes vacants c'est ce dont on parle ce
soir ya un million de postes vacants
c'est un nombre record ça prend 10 bras
pour les combler ces postes vacants les
immigrants ne représente pas la première
solution
non
le tout deux postes vacants au québec
qui inférieur au taux de postes vacants
aux états unis était feria auto de
postes vacants à cannes au britannique
par exemple
oui on a un taux de postes vacants qui
est relativement élevé au québec c'est
la première génération de gens
d'affaires qui font face à ce problème
le passé autrefois
le taux de chômage au québec étaient
toujours dans les deux chiffres sont
avec existe des 12 % de chômage alors il
n'y avait jamais demande de main
d'oeuvre y en avait toujours deux
disponibles qui est en chômage et qui te
prête à rentrer au travail mais
maintenant il faut changer notre point
de vue l'économie du québec ce n'est pas
une économie
qui est fait en arrière c'est une
économie qui est très dynamique et en
fait on se plante on regarde les villes
au canada c'est les villes du québec et
les villes de vol en début d'année qui
sont les plus dynamiques sur le plein
que l'homme et d'autres quel fromage et
bob le taux de postes et vaka forcément
est plus élevé nous c'est les premières
générations qu'on en sort nos gens
d'affaires sont en état de choc aux
açores et doivent évidemment utiliser
bien d'autres moyens que seulement
l'immigration se prendrait mon avis
impact économique entre les gens
d'affaires et le gouvernement du québec
pour déterminer ben oui on fait venir
des immigrés on s'assure que la
composition de l'immigration est bien
adaptée aux besoins réels on cherche la
pop tous les moyens de réduire le temps
d'attenté
d'améliorer la bonne fonction que les
gens qui viennent et les besoins de nos
entreprises on fait tout ça mais on peut
pas penser réussir ça si on fait passer
le taux d'immigration par exemple de
50000 par année elle s'en tenir à ce en
indiquant qu'ils arrêtent leur coeur ou
sociale josée pilotte l'opinion la
majorité des québécois de leur
entreprise va devenir très négatives ont
aussi on est plus sensible au risque
social qu'il y ait de monter
les de la population interne compte les
migrations l'équipe au québec à l'heure
actuelle nos gens sont plus favorables à
l'immigration que dans le reste du
canada on épluche à voir et à
l'immigration au québec il faut pas que
ça change dans le reste du canada mais
si on pousse confort lieu de danse avec
trop d'immigrants et ça c'est grave
danger qui menace absolument dans le
reste du canada aucun danger que ça
attise la xénophobie il éventuellement
leurs astuces et qu'on recule finalement
à 20000 ou dix mille
immigrés en force vers le haut
absolument merci beaucoup pour cette
analyse avec nous ce soir au plaisir